merci d'être notre invité secrétaire
national d'Europe Écologie Les Verts on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale bonjour Stéphane Vernet
bonjour bonjour Stéphane de westfrance
merci également d'être avec nous on va
parler de la feuille de route de la
transition écologique on imagine que
vous l'attendez avec impatience vous
l'avez eu hier soir Emmanuel Macron l'a
dévoilé on va revenir dans les détails
mais d'abord est-ce qu'il vous a
convaincu le chef de l'État hier soir je
vais vous décevoir parce que tout le
monde me pose cette question dans c'est
bon vous êtes contents maintenant les
écolos et c'est vrai que j'aurais adoré
pouvoir venir ce matin me réjouir en me
disant c'est bon tout est tout est sous
la bonne voie et tout est sous contrôle
malheureusement ça n'est pas le cas j'ai
été la première à dire que l'exercice de
planification était extrêmement
intéressante parce que le constat qui
est posé par ce document et assez lucide
inédit c'est un bon exercice mais quand
on voit tous les constats qui sont posés
par exemple on nous dit il y a 20 à 30
000 hectares qui sont artificialisés par
an en France ces deux à trois fois la
surface de Paris tous les ans qui sont
artificialisés en France quand on nous
dit à 60% des oiseaux des champs
d'Europe qui ont disparu en 40 ans quand
on y a 85 communes qui avaient plus
d'eau au robinet cet été on attend un
plan d'ampleur et quand on entend les
annonces d'Emmanuel Macron dimanche soir
et puis lundi forcément on est déçu je
vous donne deux exemples le premier
c'est des centrales à charbon en 2017
Emmanuel Macron candidat dit
en 2022 il n'y aura plus de centrale à
charbon dans ce pays bon là on est en
2023 donc on regarde le bilan bon ben
elles sont encore là et il nous dit il
prend la même phrase c'est l'économie
circulaire vous savez le recyclage il
prend la même phrase il change les dates
dis nous sommes en 2023 en 2027 il n'y
aura plus de centrage à charbon mais
comment on le croit quand c'est
exactement la même phrase dit qu'elles
sont converties en biomasse c'est pas
c'est pas une idée mais il avait dit la
même chose en 2017 en disant je m'y
engage en 2022 il y aura plus de
centrale à charbon donc 2023 ils sont
encore là le glyphosate c'est encore
plus saisissant parce que là il m'aime
il régresse sur l'objectif en 2017 là il
est président de la République et il
fait vous savez c'était au moment où il
était Greta Thunder de la scène
internationale il avait mis le hashtag
make en planète great again et il dit le
glyphosate j'ai mis en gage dans trois
ans la France on sera sorti et donc là
tous les gens ils se disent bah alors
les écolos vous êtes calmés vous savez
plus à rien l'écologie c'est Macron etc
il avait dit on sera sorti donc en 2020
du glyphosate on est en 2023 on en est
pas sorti du tout et là dans le plan
c'est écrit non mais mesures d'ampleur
on va baisser la dépendance au
glyphosate de 30%. franchement il y a
pas de solution pour les agriculteurs et
il a dit
une écologie contre les agriculteurs qui
les avait en 2017 et il les a pas en
2023 bon bah c'est un peu compliqué
quand on est président de la République
et la question n'est pas de faire de
l'écologie pour ou contre les
agriculteurs vous pensez que moi je me
lève le matin en disant bon bah
aujourd'hui je vais faire de l'écologie
contre les agriculteurs la question
c'est de leur dire aussi la vérité et si
vraiment on veut aider l'agriculture moi
je poste des mesures qui sont très
écologiques sur la table par exemple la
fin le suspension des projets de ferme
parce que les frères usines ce ne sont
pas des fermes ce sont des usines quand
vous offrez une ferme à vos enfants à
vos neveux et nièces à Noël vous offrez
pas un truc de 26 étages avec des ports
à tous les étages pas de fenêtre et des
animaux qui peuvent pas bouger vous
offrez une petite ferme La Prairie etc
c'est ça la vision d'élevage qu'on a en
France et aujourd'hui 60% de la viande
dans notre pays et produite par 3% des
exploitants dans des fermes qui sont un
désastre pour l'écologie un désastre
pour le bien-être animal et un désastre
il faut le dire pour le bien-être donc
en résumer
sa soirée à dire écologie au service de
l'économie économie économie économie
mais l'écologie française oui mais
l'écologie à la fin c'est pas pour
l'économie c'est pour les gens c'est
pour le vivant et les gens ne sont pas
dans son plan moi je voulais qu'il
explique aux Français ce qui allait
changer dans leur vie j'ai pas compris
ça alors ça ça vient peut-être après
mais vous dites que l'exercice de
planification extrêmement intéressant le
constat est lucide mais par contre sur
les méthodes ou les propositions ce que
vous attendiez à quelque chose à une
rupture et c'est ça qui vous manque
aujourd'hui dans ce dans cette dans
cette démarche parce que planification
c'est bien les réunions la communication
mais il faut de l'action et comment vous
faites une planification écolo sans le
supprimer aucun grand projet autoroutier
sans le supprimer aucun projet de méga
bassine sans le supprimer aucun projet
de faire l'usine ça marche pas et
surtout ce qu'il faut dire aux gens
puisqu'on est là pour leur dire la
vérité c'est que tous ces projets ça
coûtent énormément d'argent public
énormément d'argent public pour des
projets anachroniques obsolètes
dégradants pour l'humain pour le vivant
et donc si on économie cet argent public
si dans notre côté il en a pas du tout
parlé on met en place un ISF climatique
un impôt sur les grandes fortunes ça on
est pour depuis bien longtemps chez les
écolos mais cibler sur le climat
c'est-à-dire qu'on taxe plus celles et
ceux qui vivent de projets climaticides
et cet argent et rétribué à des
politiques écologiques alors on dégage
beaucoup de marches financières et avec
ces marches financières on peut faire un
truc très simple plus de bonheur pour
les gens faire en sorte qu'ils vivent
mieux qu'ils mangent mieux qu'ils se
déplace mais qu'ils AXA des transports
en commun de qualité qui respirer
très simple comme projet avec ce qui a
été proposé ces deux jours l'objectif de
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
55% des signes 2030 sera tenu par la
France bah là aussi je suis inquiète
parce que il dit c'est bon on a baissé
les cinq dernières années de 2% par an
les émissions de CO2 comme si c'était la
pensée magique grâce à lui donc on
continue c'est bon la réalité c'est que
non mais vous étiez là les trois
dernières années comme moi il y a eu le
covid toute l'activité économique a été
ralentie on va pas refaire un covid tous
les ans pour tenir nos objectifs CO2
[Musique]